german politicians are turning up the
pressure on nordstream
2. some of them want the project which
will deliver gas
from russia to germany and beyond to be
stopped over the poisoning of prominent
kremlin critic alexey navalny
with a powerful nerve agent opposition
from eastern european countries
and the united states has already seen
work in the baltic sea
frozen with the pipeline 90 complete
when this 480 kilometer long stretch of
pipeline is finished
it will transport oil and gas from the
controversial
nordstream 2 pipeline's terminus in
northern germany
to the south the oigal pipeline will
then carry fossil fuel energy on
to countries including the czech
republic and italy
the pipeline operators are based in
castle at germany's geographical center
the fact that nordstream 2's future is
in doubt
is going to have knock-on effects here
but managers here
don't want to talk about maybe scenarios
we bound the oigar pipeline and a
pipeline we're building the oigal
pipeline which is effectively two lines
next to each other
the first line is already in operation
and transporting gas
the second string will be finished at
the end of this year
we already have bookings for both
strings and we remain confident the
pipeline will be well used
russian gas will flow south through
pumping stations like this one
for decades the czech republic has been
getting russian gas through the
nordstream one pipeline
the czech company for gas sells 80
of russian gas deliveries on to slovakia
austria and italy it's a lucrative
business with high tax revenues
so the czech government also wants
nordstream too
in 2020 21 and 23
uh the long-term contracts which net for
gas
has from from the from the past will end
so for us as i said the beginning is
important you know to keep the flow
through the czech republic
so we support them we support north
stream too
this brings prague into opposition with
neighbouring poland and the baltic
states
which are fiercely opposed to nordstrom
2. these countries are worried the
energy
sector is too dependent on russia in
prague on the other hand the baltic sea
pipeline is viewed pragmatically
the czech republic seems to be a silent
country
in this case but its position is quite
clear
north stream 2 project is economically
beneficial for
our country will the expensive
nordstream 2 systems on the baltic coast
ever become operational
the gas customers south of germany are
the most concerned about the debate on
whether to end the pipeline project
well on this let's speak to dr thierry
bros who's a leading energy analyst and
professor at sean's pool in paris
you've just published a paper on
nordstream 2 saying the current
situation
with the pipeline laying unfinished in
the baltic
potentially for years is actually
preferable for most of the parties
involved how can that be the case
yes good morning thank you very much i
think the major mistake analysts are
doing and and you've uh do it have done
it in your
in your program you've looked at
nordstrom 2 as a copy or a follow-up of
north stream one
yes it is the same route yes it is the
same uh
fuel uh fossil fuel gas that you yes yes
that you ship
but in fact if you look at the timing
after nordstrom 2 was completed in 2011
another pipe wanted to be built by the
russian which was south stream
and south stream did meet uh eu position
and at the end of the day south stream
was never finished or
never finished as as south stream so
that's the first point
the second point is uh we in europe
wanted
and want still to have transit via
ukraine and so therefore there was until
2020 an urgency to finish
as the russian where where we're saying
it to finish nordstrom 2 because this
could help push more gas into germany
interestingly enough in december 2019
this contract has been renewed
until 2024 so for those two reasons uh
compare it to south stream and the fact
that we have a contract
in for transit in ukraine there is right
now
absolutely no urgency to finish
nordstrom 2.
so in your opinion is there a
possibility that
nordstrom 2 won't be finished
well uh this is why i started with the
uh with looking at south stream i mean
you've uh rightly said there's been a
huge investment in this and in south
stream also
and interestingly enough if you look at
south stream south stream started in
2012
and was stopped in 2014 but
interestingly enough
it was uh recast or reshape or
as a new pipe which is too extreme so
instead of
bringing gas from russia to bulgaria it
now and it is operational now brings gas
from russia into turkey so i mean
the story is not finished i mean you've
had me on your program a few times and i
think you're having
me for this story a few more times but i
think this story
will not finish with nordstrom 2 not in
operation
but there are other opportunities i mean
if you look at what europe wants to do
after 2024 we want to be an
hydrogen economy we want to have clean
hydrogen and this clean hydrogen
for right now we don't have it maybe uh
this is going to be produced
in our own countries but also maybe and
this is a german strategy this is the
eu strategy this is going to be uh
produced
in in foreign lands and this could be
produced in in russia
so this pipe story really isn't going
away then is it anytime
soon dr terry bros thank you so much for
getting us on top of this very
complicated issue
thank you very much now the european
union says
it's not ruling out imposing sanctions
on russia over the poisoning of
opposition leader
alexey navalny the case is already
having an economic impact in the country
the value of the ruble plummeted
after german doctors treated navalny and
concluded that he'd been poisoned with
novichok
a further escalation could prompt
foreign investors to pull out of russia
the economic consequences of the
poisoning of opposition leader alexei
navalny
could be significant the ruble has
already plunged to its lowest level
since the height of the coronavirus
pandemic in the spring despite that some
russians are taking the threat of new
western sanctions
in stride the government says that our
economy is improving due to the
sanctions
and we are beginning to look like a
developed country rather than a gas
station
so we are not afraid of any sanctions
i think some sanctions will be imposed
and the whole situation is quite tragic
there will be a reaction that causes
some issues we already have some
problems with the currency exchange rate
it's quite worrisome
the eu and the us have had sanctions
targeting whole sectors of the russian
economy in place
since 2014 when russia annexed crimea
further sanctions could have a massive
impact on the economy
german investors withdrew more than a
billion euros of investment capital in
the first quarter of this year
largely because of the political
situation